sorte de coquille autour de la terre et
plus il ya d'éruption violente plus
cette coquille est épaisse plus ses
effets se font sentir
mais rien ne prouve que cette coquille
de poussières volcaniques refroidi la
terre en fait il ya deux phénomènes
contradictoires garder ce dessin là la
chaleur de la du soleil qui arrive sur
la terre serait donc un peu réfléchi par
cette coquille se trouve tout autour de
l'atmosphère de la terre mais la chaleur
de la terre elle est aussi réfléchi par
la coquille vers l'intérieur
d'un côté la terre serait refroidie de
l'autre côté elle serait chaud aucun
savant sérieux ne peut dire aujourd'hui
lequel des deux phénomènes est le plus
fort
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que les vents
de la haute atmosphère juste sous la
coquille sont plus forts plus violents
les vents qui viennent du nord sont plus
froids plus fort il couvre plus de
surfaces vont plus loin
donc tout l'hémisphère nord et froid et
si cette théorie est exact et bien en
surveillant cette couche cette coquille
de poussières volcaniques
on pourra peut-être prévoir globalement
la température de l'été prochain
franchement rire est toujours
enthousiaste jean clair mais c'est
sérieux communication c'est une des
explications fournies par les savants
américains
elle a le mérite d'avoir été vérifiée
sur pas mal de observation pendant 200
ans ça sera bon pour demain les
prévisions de son guère réjouissantes
nuage abondant accompagner vous le voyez
de pluie et parfois de neige le matin du
pas de calais aux pyrénées c'est à dire
toute la partie ouest du territoire une
zone qui se déplacera ensuite vous le
voyez vers l'est dans l'après-midi et
traversera donc tout le pays
bonne nouvelle quand même les
températures seront en hausse les
affaires sociales maintenant christian
bilhac le ministre du travail s'apprête
à annoncer sans doute demain et chiffres
du chômage pour le mois de janvier on
dit que ces chiffres sont bons que pour
la première fois depuis bien longtemps
il redescendrait juste en dessous du
million de demandeurs d'emploi
mais déjà la cgt et la cfdt dénoncent
ces chiffres et accusent le gouvernement
de manipulation savait que lorsqu'un
chômeur aller s'inscrire à l'anpe pour
la première fois ils étaient reçus
immédiatement par un prospecteur placier
et donc son entrée en statistiques du
chômage se faisait à ce moment là la
ligne en pot est un principe très simple
vise à renvoyer le chômeur un
rendez-vous à quinze jours avec le
prospecteur placier ce qui décale
d'autant son entrée dans les chiffres du
chômage alors même si ce chômeur on le
retrouvera à un moment ou à un autre à
la fin du mois où l'opération a été
conduite
il va y avoir un certain nombre de gens
qui ne seront pas comptabilisés qui ne
seront comptabilisés que le mois suivant
donc le mois qui aura été choisi
permettra de faire descendre le chiffre
du chômage dotant d'une façon assez
artificiel qu'est ce que cela fait comme
différence est bien pour le mois de
janvier sur les statistiques qui seront
donc données sans doute prochainement
par le ministre
cet effet relativement léger il compte
sur dix mille demandeurs d'emploi mais
il risque d'être beaucoup plus fort au
moins de février et nos estimations nous
laisse attendre de 40 à 50 milles pour
le mois de février seconde critique vous
avez formulé ce matin on a avancé la
date de radiation
c'est un principe un peu de même nature
mais là ce n'est pas l'introduction au
chômage mais à la sortie
jusque là un chômeur été radié à
l'absence à son deuxième pointage de
l'anpe et les nouvelles mesures font
qu'ils sont radiées 48 heures après la
première absence au pointage ce qui fait
un gain d'à peu près 15 jours et de même
que pour la ligne emploi
il va y avoir radié un certain nombre de
chômeurs avant disons la date où il a
été radié antérieurement
cette mesure pour le mois de janvier a
une incidence beaucoup plus importantes
sur les chiffres puisqu'elle est de
l'ordre de 40 milles donc avec ces deux
mesures
c'est en tout
près de cinquante mille demandeurs
d'emploi qui vont être ainsi éliminés
d'une façon purement administrative des
chiffres de l'emploi de mai christian
bilhac nous donnera sa réponse et nous
annoncera donc sans doute les chiffres
officiels du chômage
c'est aujourd'hui qu'a commencé la grève
de la sécurité sociale une grève assez
largement suivi qui doit se poursuivre
encore demain et après demain et qui
entraînera sans doute des perturbations
dans le remboursement des allocations
familiales et des frais médicaux et puis
à défaut d'imprimer la sécurité sociale
je ne saurais trop vous recommander de
ne pas oublier de payer votre premier
tiers provisionnel de l'année fait cela
très vite car il ne vous reste qu'un peu
moins de 4 3h55 très précisément tir
croisé c'est le constat fait par la
lettre de l'unité l'organie ps sur la
polémique autour du chiffrage du
programme socialiste tirs croisés parce
que le gouvernement et la majorité ne
ménagent pas leurs attaques
mais aussi parce que le pc n'a pas
manqué d'apporter quelques réserves
les chiffres socialiste ne correspondant
pas aux comptes communiste parti
socialiste et parti communiste se réfère
toujours au même programme de
gouvernement
signé en 1972 mais le ps envisage les
conséquences financières immédiates du
programme commun les dépenses entraînées
par les nationalisations ne sont pas
prises en compte
tandis que le pc évaluent l'ensemble des
dépenses entraînées par le programme
commun aussi n'ont ils pas élaborer le
même type de document le ps propose un
aménagement du budget actuel pour les
huit derniers mois de 2009 178 tandis
que le pc avance pour sa part un plan de
cinq ans la comparaison des deux
documents laisse aussi apparaître une
profonde divergence dans la politique
économique
si communistes et socialistes sont
d'accord sur un smic porté à 2400 francs
il convient pour le ps que les temps en
payent une partie sous forme de
dégrèvement de charges sociales au
profit des entreprises tandis que pour
le pc les entreprises doivent payer
autre désaccord sur la façon de relancer
l'économie le ps fait confiance au
moteur de la dépense publique et accepte
un découvert budgétaire de 40 milliards
de francs tandis que le pc
mise sur une augmentation immédiate de
50 % des allocations familiales et
surtout sur le développement d'un vaste
secteur public et devant ce constat de
désaccord sur les chiffres les
communistes qui tenait aujourd'hui un
comité central à montreuil sous bois
près de paris ont renouvelé leurs
critiques contre l'initiative socialiste
charles fiterman dans ce chiffre la
confirmation du fait que quand on se
donne pas les moyens d'améliorer
vraiment la vie des gens de s'attaquer
aux causes de la crise
alors ne peut manquer de se heurter à
des difficultés sérieuses elle le fait
est que le parti socialiste ne prévoit
pas ses moyens c'est à dire
essentiellement des mesures économiques
fiscales financières qui mettent en
cause la domination les privilèges les
profits du capital et de ce que nous
appelons les riches dans la mesure où
ces moyens ne sont pas définies et mises
en oeuvre
alors effectivement les travailleurs et
leurs familles peuvent et se trouverait
frustré des améliorations sérieuse réel
durable qu'ils attendent à juste titre
voilà en tout cas un premier de réponse
pour françois mitterrand qui se soit
invité notre magazine cartes sur table
en direct de la maison de la radio à
prendre aux questions d'alain duhamel et
jean pierre elkabbach tout de suite pas
ce journal c'est à dire à 20h30
il aura peut-être à coeur de répondre
aussi à une nouvelle attaque de raymond
barre tout à l'heure à vannes
à propos de politique étrangère
changeons quoi que ce soit dans cette
ligne qui a été celle de la france
depuis 20 ans c'est notre capacité de
dialogue et notre capacité d' influence
qui vont progressivement s'évanouir
est ce que vous voulez que la france
joue son rôle en europe et dans le monde
ou est ce que vous voulez que nous
soyons une nation qui compte de moins en
moins jusqu'au moment où nous ne
compterons plus du tout quand elle est
mise comme tous les mercredis les
ministres ont d'abord adopté un projet
de loi dès de l'enseignement à l'école
privée un projet de loi qui dans un
premier temps s'était enlisé dans un
maquis procédure le texte d'aujourd'hui
devrait permettre à cet enseignement la
de mieux pouvoir s'adapter aux nouvelles
conditions économiques
et puis il vraiment un public est
intervenu pour faire une très courte
déclaration sur le franc déclaration
rapportée à la sortie par le porte
parole de l'elysée jean philippe lecat
et le président de la république a tenu
à féliciter le premier ministre de la
rapidité et de l'efficacité des mesures
qu'il a prises pour assurer la défense
du franc et il a déclaré ceci le franc
n'est pas malade de l'économie je
demande qu'on ne le rendent pas malade
de la politique
le franc qui est aujourd'hui à paris un
nouvel accès de faiblesse du dollar et
maintenant à quatre francs 84 par
rapport à lui et cette faiblesse
persistante et pour partie à l'origine
d'une nouvelle hausse des montants
compensatoires qui intéressait
agriculteurs concrètement cela rend plus
difficile les ventes de produits
agricoles français dans les pays de la
communauté est moins difficile
l'importation de produits agricoles en
provenance de ces mêmes pays de la cee
voix troisième sujet du conseil le point
sur la réforme haby une réforme qui a
maintenant tout juste six mois ou
presque six mois monsieur ministre tout
le monde continue notamment chez les
syndicats à lui tirer dessus à boulet
rouge arc comment est ce qu'on peut
faire appliquer une règle pas une
réforme seule contre tous bien vous
savez le tir en question mais surtout un
tir et air-air cela veut dire que
il ya beaucoup de choses qui se disent
qu'ils s'écrivent et y en a très peu qui
se font je constate vous pouvez
constater les parents constatent que nos
collèges nous lycée fonctionne et en ce
qui concerne alors la mise en oeuvre de
la réforme en sixième
cette sixième finalement donne davantage
satisfaction aux parents que les
sixièmes précédente
en gros une fois la situation est
beaucoup moins détériorée dans les faits
qu'on ne le dit dans les écrits mais
vous avez les enseignants contre vous
par mon dieu et les enseignants d'après
les sondages en des positions qui leur
sont particulières le fait d avoir
contre moi ne pas je crois une
caractéristique particulière je pourrais
citer une bonne douzaine de ministres
qui ont été mises de l'éducation qui ont
eu aussi des problèmes
je ne crois pas qu'il faille généraliser
et je prends pas régulier que les
syndicats au mois l'appareil des
syndicats c'est une chose l'enseignant
de base professeur dans sa classe ainsi
du doigt sa classe cette autre chose
constate que ceux là font leur travail
elles font bien un tir littéraire
dites-vous pas forcément prenons les
conseils d'école par exemple il ne
fonctionne pas pratiquement partout et
dans beaucoup d'endroits ne fonctionne
pas parce que le syndicat national des
instituteurs à boycotter ces conseils
d'école bien détrompez vous les
informations que j'ai montre que les
conseils d'école se réunissent je peux
même vous dire que pratiquement ils se
seront réunis par tous ultra normalement
et ceux ci su tout à fait normalement
c'est à dire que le directeur d'école s
et ses adjoints rencontré des
représentants des parents croyez-moi ça
se fait beaucoup plus que vous ne le
pensez pendant les heures de cours ou en
dehors des très bien jusqu'ici il s'est
passé en dehors des heures de cours
je crois que les instituteurs eux-mêmes
se rendent compte du caractère excessif
de la demande du syndicat des
instituteurs qui prétend que
une fois par une fois par trimestre il
faut ne pas accepter les élèves pendant
une demi-journée et traiter les
questions du comité des parents je me
propose soit simplement une solution
souple dans lesquels de toute façon
l'accueil des élèves peuvent être
assumées il ya des familles qui n'ont
pas la possibilité d garder leurs
enfants une fois par trimestre chez eux
une enfant peuvent pas dire ce soit
satisfaisant c'est pas tout à fait ce
que vous aviez voulu puisque c'était un
des points importants de la réforme ses
conseils mais encore une fois c'est
conseil se réunit les contrairement à ce
que dit le syndicat des instituteurs
deuxièmement l'enseignement de soutien
dans les classes de 6e alors on a
supprimé les filières d'accord il doit y
avoir un enseignement en soutien dans
les 3 matières principales
il n'a pas toujours lieu parce que y'a
c'est différent il ya des fois des
membres de loco le problème d'horaire
des choses comme ça
là non plus ce n'est pas normal ce que
vous avez recréer les kills hier c'est
pas du tout j ch
il faut quand même avoir une vision très
précise des choses pas il y a là aussi
les consignes de boycott du soutien pour
deux raisons qui sont pas du tout celles
que vous indiquez c'est pas pour des
questions de locon la peur et les ovins
jetables non il y à il ya parfois des
difficultés à libérer les élèves qui
n'ont pas besoin de soutien mais les
élèves qui ont besoin de soutien ont la
possibilité de recevoir leurs ordres de
soutien dans tous les cas et 16 heures
de soutien je donne de plus en plus je
peux vous le dire dans les collèges un
état de sixième les dernières
statistiques que j'ai qui date du mois
de décembre montrent que dans deux
établissements sur 3 ou dans deux
classes sur trois sur les le soutien est
effectivement appliquée comme il l'a
demandé il reste une sur trois villes en
recul sur trois c'est certain mais c'est
normal mais c'est une nouveauté
considérable soutien jamais en france
personne ne l'a utilisé et il faut pas
vous étonner qu une machine aussi lourde
mais tu l'as certain temps à s'adapter
je remercie le ministre wallon d'hier
alain peyrefitte a confirmé les
sanctions proposées par la commission de
discipline du parquet contre monique gay
mann vice présidente du syndicat de la
magistrature c'est à dire je vous
rappelle mutation d'office avec
abaissement d'échelon
ce syndicat avait appelé en réaction à
une courte cessation de travail
aujourd'hui et monique gaiman à tout
alors répondu au garde des sceaux
manifestement
le ministre a voulu porter un coup s'est
dit qu'à la magistrature et il veut
donner une sorte de valeur d'exemplarité
à cette sanction
cette mesure est grave aussi car elle
s'inscrit dans tout un climat de
durcissement du pouvoir tant à l'égard
des magistrats calais gafsa la fonction
publique et à l'égard des citoyens
également puisque nous assistons
actuellement à une sorte de de
dégradation des libertés avec des
pratiques ou des mesures qui ne
paraissent pas très légales telles que
la fouille systématique des véhicules
tels que la possibilité d'une mise en
détention d'étrangers expulsés par
simple voie de circulaire alors qu'il
faudrait être une loi
toutes ces mesures ce que créer un
climat d'insécurité chez les français
est en tout cas renforce les
possibilités d'intervention du pouvoir
et limite très nettement les libertés
des citoyens
la politique étrangère avec d'abord à
rome endeuillé par l'assassinât hier
d'un magistrat la réunion des trois
principaux syndicats qui dans la nuit
ont approuvé un programme économique
d'austérité c'est à dire un certain
nombre de sacrifices pour les
travailleurs italiens ce qui bien
entendu est un toujours un petit peu les
observateurs français habitués à
d'autres langages
c'est assez étonnant voici réuni 1500
délégués syndicaux qui représente 8
millions de travailleurs mais il ne
s'agit absolument pas de déclarer la
guerre au patronat les revendications
ont été mises aux vestiaires les
sacrifices pourquoi pas c'est un
tournant dans le mouvement syndical
italien moindre revendication si cela
peut permettre de redresser la situation
économique
on accuse souvent les syndicats italiens
de faire trop de concessions au patronat
c'est une chose qui peut être
pourrait se justifier s'il y avait un
gouvernement de gauche en italie
seulement ce n'est pas le cas comment
justifiez-vous ces concessions mais
probablement la ligne proposée par le
syndicat italien est un peu curieuse
pour les travailleurs des autres pays
mais je dois préciser qu' il n'y a
aucune concession de la part du syndicat
nous proposons une ligne qui a trois
points très strictement liés entre eux
c'est à dire nous proposons une
politique d'austérité
une politique économique de
planification et nous revendiquons le
contrôle syndicats sur l'entreprise et
le système économique
c'est tout un programme économie
prudents et modérés que proposent les
syndicats
seulement voilà luciano lama le
secrétaire général de la cgt italienne
vient de dire qu'il était normal que les
entreprises en difficulté licencient
leurs employés alors évidemment la base
syndicale a du mal à suivre
il y a des préoccupations les
préoccupations c'est de voir vraiment
réaliser cette ligne mais ça ne dépend
pas seulement du syndicat ça dépend
surtout du nouveau gouvernement que nous
devrons avoir
et du nouveau programme que ce
gouvernement devra exprimer
que fera le prochain gouvernement c'est
à dire les partis politiques les
syndicats veulent bien la paix sociale
ou du moins l'armistice sociale mais si
les partis politiques ne suivent pas il
y aura de nouveau des problèmes avec la
base syndicale
tout se passe comme si les syndicats
disaient au patronat et aux partis
politiques ne nous obligez pas à
mobiliser nos troupes
quand on pense qu'il n'y a pas
l'équivalent de l'expression consensus
social en italien dit hubert l'homme
politique bavarois relevé hier a été
retrouvé aujourd'hui sain et sauf il a
tout de même passé quarante quatre
heures dans différents coffre de voiture
les rapports franco algérien aujourd'hui
encore en conseil des ministres valéry
giscard d'estaing a défini un nouveau
cadre pour les relations entre paris et
alger
dans le droit fil de ce qu'il proposait
la semaine dernière à la télévision
c'est à dire une tentative de
restauration des rapports il est vrai
que ceux ci se sont bien dégradées ne
prenons que le seul exemple de
l'économie sachez que maintenant la
france n'est plus que le troisième
partenaire de l'algérie derrière les
américains et les allemands
diplomatie économies pour paris et alger
l'un ne va pas sans l'autre
c'est le drame de nos relations des
relations qui ne peuvent être que
passionnels dans les rues d'alger
réchauffé par le soleil d'un hiver
clément la présence de l'économie
française est bien visible dans le flot
d'une circulation intense mais dans ces
rues où certains français ont laissé
bien des souvenirs d'autres entreprises
européennes et même américaines ont fait
une percée impressionnante pour eux
l'algérie n'est qu'un partenaire comme
les autres il n'y a ni complexe ni
susceptibilités les américains ne sont
pas gênés par les options socialiste de
l'algérie il apporte une grande partie
de leur production de gaz
les allemands de l'ouest arrive avec
leurs grosses mercedes
la chimie est l'un de leurs atouts
commencé avec une petit bureau avec deux
personnes et petit à petit on a grandi
avec notre bureau jusqu'au 9
départements pour le moment est ce que
vous avez eu des difficultés au début
oui parce qu'elle s'était une marché
français avant et on a un peu de
difficulté avec le client parce que
c'est obligatoire que l'algérien acheté
chez les français à votre avis pourquoi
les français ne réussissent pas
actuellement en algérie
est ce que vous ne pensez pas qu'il y
ait des raisons politiques ça ne s'est
pas parce que si j'ai parlé avec les
gens qui achètent produit chez nous on
parle seulement du prix livraison des
après-ventes jamais des politiques
même si les nouveaux partenaires
économiques de l'algérie ne veulent pas
l'avouer il est évident que la
conjoncture actuelle leur profite
cela est très net dans le constantinois
cb
w
cette région de constantine est devenue
l'une des zones industrielles les plus
importantes de l'algérie création d'
usine de machines-outils de forge et de
fabrication de tracteurs dans cet énorme
ensemble industriel pas une seule
entreprise française
peut-on dire alors que les algériens
sont devenus anti français pour
installer ce complexe
les ingénieurs qui ont fait leurs études
à paris ont dû se mettre à la langue
allemande
on a eu des difficultés de part la
langue
et puis deux par set l'anglais également
des difficultés de contacter une
entreprise française qui permet ici ça
aurait été plus facile pour vous ça
c'est certain de par le manque
assurément de de l'algérie qui est un
pays quand même où la langue française
est là et quand même très utilisé c'est
certain que le marché algérien profiter
énormément aux industriels français
ici les industriels français se présente
comme n'importe quel commerçant afin
qu'ils voudraient vendre son petit
produit et c'est à dire 7 6 en une une
vente actuel qui n'a qui n'a pas
d'effets dix ans ni à moyen ni à long
terme ce qui est 10 ans si je ne
comprends par rapport aux industriels
allemands
c'est de loin ceux ci industriels se
présente dix ans comme étant des
partenaires et non pas comme étant des
vendeurs dans ce sont des gens qui
mettent à notre disposition dans un
premier temps leurs produits et dans un
deuxième temps leur technologie on dit
aussi qu'il ya peut-être des raisons
politiques
il ya certainement des raisons
vous savez leur complique cependant dans
la nasse evas autre raison de notre
échec en algérie certains industriels
français ne croient pas à l'avenir de ce
pays qui pourtant est le plus
industrialisé de l'afrique du nord et le
plus riche en matières premières
en réalité nos relations avec l'algérie
ne peuvent être qu'exceptionnel et le
facteur psychologique primordial les
plaies de la guerre d'algérie et de tous
les drames qui ont suivi ne sont pas
encore cicatrisées
mais pour combien de temps encore
nous annoncions hier la décision de
jimmy carter de vendre des avions de
chasse à l'egypte et à l'arabie saoudite
réactions amères de menahem begin
aujourd'hui à la knesset
il demande au président américain de
revenir sur sa décision
qui at il dit a augmenté le risque de
danger de confrontations au proche
orient
deux informations maintenant dans le
monde de l'environnement la nomination
de jean-françois saglio qui sera
désormais déléguée à la qualité de la
vie et puis la mort de rené richard l'un
des pionniers de la lutte pour
l'environnement en france il est avoir
74 ans c'était un défenseur acharné des
sites de la côte d'azur en particulier
et le vice président de l'association
espace pour demain c'était aussi l'un
des fondateurs respecté de force
ouvrière voici maintenant le genre
d'informations qui nous prend à la gorge
parce que les vraiment atroce et
lincendie d'une vieille maison en bois à
lens mal à moi n'est ses six enfants et
deux locataires dormait quand le feu les
a surpris un peu provoqué semble-t-il
par une explosion d'un appareil de
chauffage au mazout et ne s'occupant de
la maison sont morts et donc la maman et
ses six enfants âgés de 5 à 16 ans il
reste une petite fille de 10 ans qui ne
dormaient pas ce soit relâché samedi une
suite à ce que nous vous disions lundi
le procès du talc morhange aura
finalement lieu en octobre prochain à
pontoise
cela fait six ans que les familles
attendent et puis à partir de demain une
campagne en faveur des dons d'organes en
france vous pouvez trouver dans toutes
les pharmacies donc à partir de demain
des cartes
il faut que vous nous expliquiez marqué
lario à quoi ça va servir et à une
précision organes mêmes tissus vivants
vous pouvez commencer à donner des
tissus quand vous n'êtes pas encore mort
et puis après votre mort vous pouvez
donner des composés s'engage beaucoup de
personnes dans leur sang vous savez
parfois de la moelle osseuse parfois de
la pause on peut faire de son vivant
et puis après la mort on peut donner un
coeur de reins des yeux alors il devra
aussi donner un corps entier une loi qui
a essayé de d'instituer cela il ya un an
commencez qui a fait un énorme effort
puisque maintenant au lieu de donner
l'autorisation de prélever un corps la
loi a renversé le problème c'est à dire
qu'il faudra donner une interdiction
pour qu'on ne puisse pas prélevé un
organe alors ça c'est la théorie
on attend un décret d'application qui
depuis un an est très difficile à
rédiger et qui ne sort pas et en
attendant peu de personnes sont
informées ce qui fait que pour l'instant
on n'a pas assez de donneurs d'organes
des personnes qui sont en dialyse rénale
qui ont les reins qui ne sont plus en
état de marche attendent désespérément
une greffe de rein sans l'avoir parce
que sous le coup de l'émotion
les familles refusent généralement que
l'on donne le corps de l'un des proches
quand il est mort alors cette campagne
d'explication cette affiche ses cartes
vont permettre à toute personne de
savoir exactement quelles conditions sas
par les conditions humanitaires de façon
à ce que tout aille bien
je remercie martine voilà c'est ainsi
que se termine ce journal je vous le
rappelle une fois de plus que la météo
est mauvaise pour demain le matin dans
l'est et l'après midi dans l'ouest
n'oubliez pas vos deux rendez vous
d'actualité la soirée 20h30 en semi de
carence te dire dans quatre minutes
maintenant et 22h30 tous à peu près le
dernier journal de patrick le coach vous
souhaite à tous une excellente soirée et
j'espère vous retrouver demain